[Music]
just do something for my heart you know
Kanye West is back on social media and
so are his bizarre tweets the rapper
reactivated his Twitter on Sunday
sharing a few fond memories with his
followers starting with this screenshot
of his favorite Saint Pablo TV featuring
Caitlyn Jenner who is now estranged from
her stepdaughter
Kanye's wife Kim Kardashian then Kanye
shared a very heartfelt memory from
Lamar Odom's recovery after the former
NBA pro was hospitalized and found
unconscious in a Nevada brothel quote my
favorite moment of walking into MSG to
play st. Pablo I used to go to the
hospital and play Lamar the album when
he was learning to walk and talk again
then we walked into the arena together
not long after that show the Kardashian
family seemingly cut ties with Lamar
like any of the songs feel free to dance
easy also posted to neck tattoo designs
he's considering getting both dedicated
to his two-year-old son st. it's
extremely important to me naturally an
odd Kanye rant rolled in to the famous
rapper wrote some people have to work
within the existing consciousness while
some people can shift the consciousness
adding often people working with the
existing consciousness are jealous of
those who are more in touch
[Music]
you